[موسيقى]
ذات مرة المال مدى الحياة
مرحبا بكم في التزلج ، أليس كذلك في جزيرة
tavolara اسمي يعارض عامل واحد
لكن الجميع يدعوني الملك الملك تونينو
جلالة المعايير التي دعاها
جوزيبي برتوليني للملك للحضور
الصيد في تافولارا أكثر من هؤلاء
الماعز البري الذهب الأسنان ليك كان لدينا
بلد سام
نعم لقد رأيته أيضًا ويبدو أنه كذلك
كان مجرد سلالة من الماعز
يقول البعض إنهم يصنعون نوعًا ما
يأكلون من العشب لذلك أتيت إليه
سأقضي المنزل الذي اتخذته اللمسة السادسة إلى الثالثة
وبعد ذلك كانت تلك العروس تريد حقها
قال بالضبط أنه تم تعيينه ملكا
جعله tavolara تذكرة
مكتوبًا بالبوتوكس أو بالطلاء الصغير
رحلة إد لجعل الموجة لا تزال تحتفظ بها
هناك لهذه الصورة الأصلية التي تحتوي على
الزوجين لدينا
يتبع مناقشة اليوم ما أفعله
أنا رياضة بالنسبة لي ، فهي تنطلق من الصيد
أنا أستمتع هنا في المنزل لأقوم بوظائف غريبة
أنا أعمل في المطعم من جولان مرير
[موسيقى]
فيدرر مثل البيئة التي ولدت فيها
أنا أعتبر من نسل الملك وبالتالي
كالذكر الأول
دائما يأخذ العنوان كما أفعل
الحاكم وبالتالي
هي ايطاليه
إنه جزء من إيطاليا
ومع ذلك فهي مملكة الجداول التي تنتمي إليها
نحن
مع أريسا
مكان مثل هذا حتى يكون صحيحًا
تحتاج تاج كولد بلاي 2